[Applause]
no glamorous red carpet no adoring
crowds no comedy acts
instead of a fancy theater the awards
will be handed out in an
art deco era train station after a
pandemic year in which the movie
industry itself struggled and streaming
video
extended its dominance over cinema
releases the oscars will be
more low-key this year not a lot of fun
maybe i'm i'm
so sick of virtual award shows right now
and people in their living rooms on zoom
among the best picture nominees director
chloe zhao's nomad land
is the front runner my mom says that's
your homeless is that
true no i'm not homeless i'm just
houseless not the same thing right no
best actor award may come down to a
choice between honors for the late
chadwick boseman in ma rainey's black
bottom look at the heart i got peter
and anthony hopkins in the father who
are you
actually it's me paul oh i live here
what is this nonsense i would have said
chadwick boseman
for sure and i have predicted that but
i'm noticing some members talking about
oh they think chadwick's going to win
but they're voting for anthony hopkins
the best actress award is up for grabs
with strong performances by viola davis
in maharani's black bottom
all they want is my boy francis
mcdormand in nomad land
carrie mulligan and promising young
woman vanessa kirby in pieces of a woman
facing this i am facing it i am facing
this
and andra day in the united states
versus billie holiday
i think i'm gonna stop singing that song
you grandkids will be saying strange
fruit
in contrast to recent years a large
number of black hollywood professionals
were nominated and
stephen yin is the first korean american
nominated for best actor
in minari riz ahmed is the first muslim
and first person of pakistani descent
nominated for best actor
in sound of metal i can't hear you do
you understand me i can't i'm deaf
i'm and nomad lands zhao
is the first asian-american woman
nominated for best director
it may have been a rough year for
hollywood but the cachet
of the little gold figurine remains
strong the ratings are going to be
in the tank but the oscar still stands
for
something it is the primo thing everyone
wants one in the industry
in a year like no other the show somehow
goes on rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles